official story on 9/11 is a complete
lie. The 9/11 report is a joke.
>> You have the CIA following two men all
over the planet and then eventually even
to America, right? And you don't tell
the FBI 911 commission cover up.
>> So, what did happen? What did the
government know? What did foreign
governments know? There was a cover up.
Why? It's been nearly 25 years. It is
time Americans learned what actually
happened. You were not allowed to follow
up in any of this. Fox News did a series
with Brit Hume and Carl Cameron, which
many people have seen in a bootleg
version on the internet, but they did it
like within weeks saying, "What is
this?" There was an Israeli spy ring in
the United States, and they clearly knew
911 was coming. This is Fox News. They
pulled that under pressure. They pulled
that off the internet. It's not
searchable in any Fox News archive, but
they aired it. I know the people who who
did it, of course. I worked with them
for years.
>> Let me be honest. It's people like
Tucker Carlson that is going to bring
the truth to light. So many people in
America are waking up and the Israels
are crapping theirelves.
Guys, before the video starts, brothers
and sisters, one Umar is working in
Pakistan with a flood that's hit the
country. 1,700 people have lost their
life. Millions of people have lost their
homes and been displaced. So the videos
that you can see here, the pictures that
you can see guys, is demonstrating what
one is doing on the ground. We know Gaza
is important and we know what's going on
there. But brothers and sisters, we
cannot enable and turn a blind eye to
the suffering of Muslims in different
countries. Be it Pakistan, be it Turkey,
the earthquakes, wherever it may be,
Afghanistan, so many other places need
our help. And I know all of us have
given as much as we can to Gaza. But
brothers and sisters, wahi, just imagine
your home wrecked. Thousands of people
have died. Your family members have
passed away. You have nowhere to live.
Brothers and sisters, they need our help
as much as Gaza does. So I urge you
guys, inshallah, it's 100% donation
policy. donate whatever amount even if
it's one pound. The prophet peace be
upon him said the best form of sodak is
to give water. Brothers and sisters,
let's give them food and shelter and
water to drink so they can overcome this
tragedy. Inshallah, I urge you guys to
go to the link and donate now. Enjoy the
video.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends,
the whole world is waking up to the plot
and plans that the Zionists have been
doing for decades. These people are so
vile and the entire world has woken up
to the plans, the plotting, the false
flag attacks they've been doing on US
Liberty ship to 9/11 to JF Kennedy's
killing. Call it conspiracy. Call it
whatever you like. It's not coincidence.
It is not a coincidence. And here is the
footage of Piers Morgan and Tucker
Carson. And the American people are
waking up. They're waking up. It's the
beginning of the end of Israel. Here's
what they have to say.
>> And I'm really struck. We spent the last
four months looking into 9/11,
reassessing the explanations we were
given by the government for 911. And one
of the things that really struck me was
the viciousness with which anyone who
questioned it, certainly in the in the
first several years, um was treated
with. You know, they were dismissed as
crazy. By the way, I participated in
that. I attacked people who questioned
9/11. So, I I'm very culpable there. But
there's a very simple way to dispel
conspiracy theories to make people with
dumb ideas look foolish and that's by
disclosing what actually happened. It's
by telling the truth. It's through
transparency that you gain trust. It's
not I mean if your children if you ask
your children where were you last night?
I'm not going to tell you. Does that
engender trust? Of course not. It
destroys it. And so there's also a sense
in which it's outrageous that the US
government could presume to hide from
the people who own the country, the
citizens, the truth about an event that
changed the nation more than any other
in our lifetimes any any since the civil
war. It's a completely different country
since 911. Millions of people died in
the aftermath of 9/11. And so what
exactly is the justification for not
telling us what happened that day? And
and they haven't.
>> Exactly. What is the justification? I
can remember before I came to Islam,
subhan Allah, this thing of 9/11 and I
was looking into it. I was watching a
lot of videos and then I came across a
website which I'm going to share with
you guys in called Rethink 911. As you
can see on the page, dawn is coming
September 13th, 10:00 a.m. And these are
demolition experts, fire brigades, fire
uh firemen, you know, scientists who are
looking at this and saying it doesn't
add up. It doesn't add up. And believe
me, when you go down that rabbit hole,
it gets deeper and deeper. And as you as
you can see 911 whistleblower, I urge
you guys to watch that as well cuz
Tucker Carson goes in detail and believe
me the American people are waking up to
who really controls their country, the
United States of Israel. Let's carry on.
>> Official story on 9/11 is a complete
lie. The 9/11 report is a joke.
>> You have the CIA following two men all
over the planet and then eventually even
to America, right? And you don't tell
the FBI 911 commission cover.
>> So what did happen? What did the
government know? What did foreign
governments know? There was a cover up.
Why? It's been nearly 25 years. It is
time Americans learned what actually
happened.
>> Of course they know. Of course they know
what happened. The Saudi individuals uh
11 of how many I don't know how many of
them? Seven or 11 of them I can't
remember. hijacking planes, coming here,
coming to America, learning how to fly
planes, crashing into the buildings.
Their pass will survive, of course.
Bulletproof passports, 100% definitely.
And for some odd reason, they go and
invade Iraq. Makes perfect sense.
Afghanistan
makes perfect sense. Makes perfect
sense. That's current. That was that was
the trailer, and I cannot wait to watch
it myself. Inshallah, do check out. But
let's see what Pier Morgan had to say.
You know, I hope you guys enjoyed the
video, guys. But before that, please
download the Salah Pro app, brothers and
sisters. We are a charity. All of our
services on the app is for free. Free
kibla finder, no ads, free salah
reminders, encourages to pray, tells you
salah times. You can book a salah
instructor, a Quran instructor. You can
order a guided prayer map for absolutely
free if you want to learn how to pray
salah. Videos on how to pray salah,
salah hubs, and many, many more brother
sisters. We are not an app that shares
your information with third parties. All
of our services on the app is for free.
Download it now inshallah and enjoy,
guys. Let's go back to the video. The
plane that hit the Pentagon was in the
San Diego phone book and he was being
followed by the CIA. I mean, this is all
documented. And not just by the CIA, by
foreign intel services, probably the
British, possibly the French, definitely
the Israelis. They knew. Now, I'm not
alleging that they committed 9/11, but I
am stating because it's a fact that they
were aware the hijackers were in the US
and were planning a terror attack
against the United States. and they
never passed information to the FBI, to
local police, much less to the American
public, and 3,000 people died as a
result. So what is that? Huge parts of
the 911 story were left out of the
commission report.
>> Why isn't it impossibility? Governments
have done false attacks for centuries.
It's one of the tool the tools they use
in the tool uh tool book. You know,
that's that's what they do. They do
false attacks so they can blame it on.
That's what the liberty was. The US
liberty was attacked. Why? because they
can the Israelis wanted the Americans to
join in and that's what they've been
doing and not only that you'll be
shocked to find out what Benjamin thel
may Allah rip him soul into peace
inshallah what he said about this guys
you'll be shocked for example what
happened in building 7 which was not
only not next to the twin towers which
are hit by airplanes but had a building
in between itself and those buildings
collapsed that afternoon for reasons
that no one has been able to explain
since you're not a lunatic for asking
there is no re-elect. There's no
plausible explanation for how that
building collapsed. So, let's talk about
that.
>> It's not even mentioned.
>> Well, let's talk about that for a moment
because it's one of the many, you know,
things that have raged since. Um, if you
look into the investigation into Tower
7, the findings of the investigation
into it were that the North Tower when
it came down had set off a load of fires
in building 7. That and it was a steel
structure and shouldn't have gone down,
but it did. that these fires burned all
afternoon and I think it was about 5:00
in the afternoon or something that that
the tower eventually gave way to the
welter of fires raging inside it.
>> Get the hell out of here, man. Get the
flipping hell out of here, man. Wall
train center 7 felt. It's like
demolition. It's like full demolition. A
free fall. Yes. The whole entire man,
this is against physics, man. This is
science, man. And you're telling me
debris and fire from there caused that
to collapse? Nowhere in history has fire
that started from another building or
wherever causes an entire structure like
that to fall free fall. Get out of here,
man. Get the hell out of here.
Knowledge. By the way, there was a team,
this is according to the FBI, by the
way. This is the FBI saying, there was a
team of clearly intelconnected
foreigners who were arrested after 911,
as you well know, um, videotaping
the terror attacks. This is I'm almost
verbatim quoting from the FBI assessment
of this. And the FBI determined that
they apparently had fornowledge of the
attacks. So why can't we know more about
that? Exactly. Okay. Just this this
here. Watch this video, guys. I'm going
to play a little video for you guys on
YouTube. Unbelievable.
Check this out, guys. Yeah. Okay. Ladies
and gentlemen, in this video, I'm going
to be going over a very interesting
story. It is the story of the dancing
Israelis. Now, I'm sure many of you
might have a very vague recollection of
the phrase dancing Israelis. And I'm
guessing a lot of you probably think in
your mind that it was some conspiracy
theory or that it was fake or that it
was some type of anti-semitic stuff. It
was 1,000% real. So real to the point of
the government having to declassified
photos of the five dancing Israelis
because of a Freedom of Information Act
request. and I'm going to review
everything that transpired related to
the story. Now, the main part of the
story did happen on September 11th, 2001
in New York City, but there was a lot of
leadup and a lot of things that happened
after the fact as well. A simple
definition of the dancing Israelis were
five men perched from an advantageous
position in clear view of both towers,
dancing, posing, and celebrating with a
camera as the towers burned in the
background. It was so noticeable, a
bystander who was looking at the towers
with binoculars over the top of the
parking lot reported the five men to the
police along with their white van, which
supposedly was part of their moving
company, Urban Movers. The men left in
their white van sometime after both
towers were hit. At around 3:00 in the
afternoon on September 11th, an alert
went out to the police to look for this
white van. A few hours later, they were
able to track it down. The van was
pulled over and the men were
investigated in New Jersey. The five
Israelis originally denied having
involvement in this event, saying their
advantageous view was just a coincidence
and that they got there after the first
building was hit. However, it was later
reported that the white van was seen
there at around 8:00 a.m. Eastern
Standard Time before the first plane was
hit. I should also make a note here that
the five men claimed they saw the towers
burning and that attracted them to the
advantageous position. The US government
has confirmed that there are photographs
that exist of the five men smiling,
laughing, and even in one instance
holding up a lighter right under where
one of the towers was burning. There
were around 80 total photos. The
arrested Israelis were caught with money
in their socks and tested positive for
explosive residue in their van and on
their clothing. The company that they
worked for, Urban Movers, was later
found to be a shell company started by
another Israeli. When the FBI went to
question him 3 days after September
11th, he fled to Israel. It was said
that there was an abnormal amount of
computers located inside the moving
company's offices. They were all seized
by the FBI. The five men were held for
70 days and then deported back to Israel
where they later admitted on Israeli TV
that they were in New York City as MSAD
agents there to document the event. The
MSAD is the National Intelligence Agency
of Israel. So, how is that really
possible? You cannot make this up. You
cannot make this up.
Five Israelis
before the planes hit, after they hit,
they are rejoicing. Then they admit they
have connections to Mossad.
I I guys guys these people are evil.
Every evil that happens on this earth
they are behind 99% of them. Why? For
the greater Israel plan. And the whole
world is waking up. The whole world as
Zionists that are watching this are
smile. They know. They know what they're
about. They know they've been doing
this. They don't care about like Candace
Owen said today they came the guards the
children tomorrow it's going to be your
care they'll take everybody out with
their Samson option the nuclear weapons
that they have they will take America
out you dare to
um jeopardize or be a threat to their
existence they will take everybody out
this is how evil they are shut up that's
bigoted no this is my country actually I
know people who died on 9/11 everything
was changed because of it I promptly
went off to the Middle East um just like
everyone else in our business. I'm sure
you did as well. And and then we lost
our civil liberties at home. We
immediately started torturing people and
locking up people for years. They are
still locked up in Guantanamo Bay with
no charges at all. And the rest of us,
very much me included, nodded our heads
and like, "Yeah, they're bad. They're
Muslim terrorists." Now, I think a lot
of them were bad and they were Muslim
terrorists. On the other hand, if your
government is allowed to torture people
and lock them up indefinitely without
charging them, how long before they do
that to you? We don't do that here. I
know it's very common in the UK now,
which is an authoritarian country. We
don't want that here. And 9/11
dramatically changed our assumptions
about what the government is allowed to
do. So, and and by the way, I should say
the main beneficiary in the United
States of those attacks was the CIA,
which allowed them to happen. So the CIA
budget became, you know, more than
doubled. Of course, we're not allowed to
know what the CIA budget is, even in
government. This is a fact, by the way.
If you ask a high level official at the
White House currently, what's the CIA's
full budget? They can't tell you. So,
okay, let's see what Pierers Morgan has
to say.
>> What you're suggesting with your
phrasiology about that is that the CIA
were part of a kind of inside track
knowledge about what may happen, which
is obviously an incredibly serious
>> not suggesting that. I'm not suggesting
that. I'm I'm stating the facts, which
are that the CIA was fully aware that
many of these hijackers were here, that
those visas were issued in a country
with which we have very close security
service cooperation at a time when John
Brennan was running a station there.
>> But that's different to saying that they
knew what was going
>> whereabouts.
Well, they actually did know that these
people were planning a terror attack
because they surveiled a meeting
planning it in Koala Lumpur, Malaysia a
year before and then followed the guy as
he came to the United States and arrived
in San Diego for flight training. So
again, I'm not guessing about any of
this. These are established facts.
There's no person, including then CI
director George Tennant, who would deny
this. They'll say, "Oh, you're a
conspiracy theor theorist." Okay, fine,
whatever. Attack my character as you
will, but tell me how I'm wrong. And of
course, I'm not wrong. So, all you're
suggesting, I'm not saying you're right
or wrong or anything. All I'm saying is
that from everything you're saying, it
is a leap. It is a leap. There is a
demonstrable difference. I would argue,
and by all means push back on this, but
I would argue that there's a
demonstrable leap between knowledge of
bad people moving around and maybe
monitoring them and aware they may be up
to bad things, but actually having
coherent, clear knowledge in advance,
that they were planning the attack using
planes on the World Trade Center.
>> I I understand I understand you're
you're saying that intent matters, and I
would not of course I would not dispute
that intent does matter. It matters
under the law and it matters morally.
Did you mean to do it? Yes, that matters
>> 100%. Get the hell out of here, man.
There's free options. Israel done it
100%. Everyone in the world knows this.
It's a open secret. Let's go with they
didn't do it, but they had knowledge of
it, but they let it happen. Number
three, they didn't do it, but Benjamin
clearly said that he was happy that it
happened. You're a sicko if you done it.
If you knew it, but allowed it. And if
it did happen, you didn't know and you
were happy about it. You're a sicko.
That's like the far right like Tommy
Robinson whose friends colleagues have
admitted he gets happy. Yes. He gets
happy when terrorist attacks happen
because it suits his agenda. How sick do
you have to be that you are happy when
an attack happens of innocent people
because it suits your agenda?
>> You're a sicko.
>> I mean we've had do with Donald Trump.
There were two attempts on his life in
the run-up to the last election.
>> That's correct.
>> One was this young kid who appeared to
have absolutely
nothing on his files whatsoever. We seem
to know nothing about this person. He
just somehow existed in a total vacuum
of any information. Uh and the second
guy a few weeks later was able to sit in
a bush for 12 hours preparing to
assassinate Donald Trump if he'd walked
up uh about 500 yards up a golf course
to where he was waiting by one of the
Greens. And I found that deeply
unsettling because you would have
thought that Trump by then would be the
most protected human being in history
having just survived an assassination
attempt. Both of those cases raised all
sorts of questions which we just don't
know the answers to and that's happened
in the last year.
>> Well, it's clear I mean uh when you see
Trump uh getting the seat out for
Benjamin Netanyahu, it makes sense those
assassinations. Who was it orchestrated
by how it was done? You know, you can
see the America's service to Israel over
their own interests when millions of
Americans are living on the streets and
they send billions of pounds to Israel
to the lobby, you know, and look, look,
of course, man. Of course, it's going to
bring the chair out for Benjamin
Netanyahu. Those assassinations, I
wonder who orchestrated them and said,
Trump, you know, you know, these things
can happen, you know, if you know, if
you don't fix up, my friend,
>> you can attack me all you want. Don't
really care. Why don't you answer the
question, how does this work? And why
can't I know? And if I can't know, who
has greater authority than I do as a
taxpayer and a citizen?
>> Israel, my friend. Israel. Israel.
Israel.
>> You're really revealing is that the
system itself is utterly fake. Okay, I
guess everyone knows that now. But what
are the consequences of knowing that?
The consequences of knowing that are
dire and scary and and so I think at
this very late date, we should try to
fix it. And the only way to fix it is by
telling people the truth and reading
them in as as they say in Washington.
Read me in to what my government is
doing with my money in my name. And if
you won't do that, then at a certain
point like how is it not justified to
try to replace the government? Like that
actually is tyranny. What what's the
other definition of tyranny? I don't you
know like so they're really playing with
fire. I don't want revolution. I can't
stand violence. I civil war is the worst
thing that could ever happen. But I'm
not calling for any of that. I'm merely
saying that's going to happen at some
point if they don't make good on the
core promise, which is it's your
country. It exists for your benefit. You
have a right to know relevant things.
You can't just be dismissed with the
back of the hand and called names. Keep
that [__] up and you know it will get
really ugly.
>> Okay, let's carry on. Let's see last two
clips inshallah. in your in your series,
um, do you do you dispel some of the
sort of matter conspiracy theories? And
I'll give an example which you may or
may not agree with me as mad, but
there's been a raging conspiracy theory
ignited again by what's happened in Gaza
that Israel was somehow uh implicated in
9/11. It was in their interests for that
to happen because then it would lead
rage against all their enemies in the
Middle East and so on. Um and yet of
course if you look at the people who
died at least I think 110 or more people
who died that day were known to be
Jewish. It is estimated maybe another 80
were Jewish which meant that about 10%
of all the victims that day were likely
to have been Jewish which would seem to
dispel
>> how does that dispel anything? It
doesn't dispel nothing. uh at the end
they have a a um a protocol uh the
Hannibal directive which they kill their
own people they don't care they're
hostages they don't give a damn about
the host hostages man they see that as
you know what will sacrifice them for
the greater goal of Israel 10 Jews or
Zionists or whatever they're going to
get killed innocent people innocent
people there they will they they harm
their own pe they don't care these
people Zionist have worked with Hitler
they've worked with damn Hitler bro and
you think they care about They look at
the bigger picture. Five of us get
killed, but we can save 100 couple
hundred thousand. Let it be. Let it be.
>> The suggestion this was some Jewish
thing that they had been involved with.
But do you do you tackle that kind of
conspiracy theory?
>> I wouldn't say a Jewish thing. I would
say a Zionist thing. Yes. You know, just
cuz every Zionist is Jew doesn't mean
it's a Jewish thing at all. Not at all.
>> A series. In other words, as well as
exploring stuff that you think needs to
be highlighted and exposed and we need
to know more about, do you also dispel
stuff which has been allowed to rage
around for maybe 25 years now and kill
that off?
>> Well, it it hasn't so much been allowed.
It's actually been greatly discouraged.
Um, I don't repeat every theory about
it. They're endless. And I don't really
see the point in elevating things that
you know we can't know are true. I would
say the effect on me was to make me more
suspicious. Actually the and again we
didn't interview people who gather their
information about 911 from the internet.
We interviewed only people who are
directly involved in the events and the
subsequent events. So government
officials. It was almost exclusively
government officials. And during the
course
uh experience, I became more prone to
believe that this is really really bad.
This is super bad. And as to the
question that you asked specifically
about Israel, um no, of course I didn't
allege that, you know, the Jews did it.
I I don't even know what that means. I I
think in fact saying things like that is
a way to discredit um
>> real questions. Like we know I mean
Benjamin Netanyahu on camera right after
said this is a good thing because it
brings the United States into a conflict
that we've been involved in on an
existential level for decades. I mean he
said that out loud. I'm not guessing you
can pull the tape. We know that a group
of Israeli art students who clearly were
not art students. Clearly some of them
were aligned with Israeli intelligence
were arrested and held for quite some
time in the United States before being
released without charges. And we know
that a group of them, again, I'm quoting
an FBI document here, not the internet,
filmed the attacks on 911. And I'm
quoting, seem to have fornowledge of
those attacks.
>> Unbelievable. My friend, my friend, just
call it out as it is, bro. It's Zionist
scumbags who have orchestrated this.
They've orchestrated it. Simple as that,
man. The proof is in the pudding.
>> You were not allowed to follow up in any
of this. Fox News did a series with Brit
Hume and Carl Cameron, which many people
have seen in a bootleg version on the
internet, but they did it like within
weeks, saying, "What is this? There was
an Israeli spy ring in the United
States, and they clearly knew 911 was
coming. This is Fox News." They pulled
that under pressure. They pulled that
off the internet. It's not searchable in
any Fox News archive, but they aired it.
I know the people who who did it. Of
course, I worked with them for years.
They're real people. They're not crazy.
In fact, they're pro- Israel, but they
had a fact set before them and they
reported it, which is called journalism.
And subsequent
generations have been forbidden from
noting what is now factually true. Those
are factually true statements. Now, we
tried to interview some of those people.
One lives in the United States in
California and made no headway
whatsoever. And we knew as we did it, by
the way, they were going to be attacked
as anti-semmites or some anti-semite.
Obviously, I'm not even anti-Israel on
some principled level. I'm an American,
and I think it's not only fair, but my
my moral obligation to find out what the
hell was this. And you're calling me
names is not going to stop me because
I've been here my whole life and my
family's been here a long time. I I
don't have to take orders from you about
what I'm allowed to know or not know
because it's my country. That's that's
the kind of democratic spirit that
informed this country my entire life
until 911 after which it became a
thought crime to ask obvious questions
and I'm just not going to play along.
Period. Let me be honest. It's people
like Tucker Carlson that is going to
bring the truth to light. It's people
like him who's going to be vocal about
it doing about it that the entire world
is going to woke up wake up because
other people just silent and name
calling Candace Owens himself. So many
people in America are waking up and the
Israels are crapping theirelves. Here's
the last clip in
>> that this focus on Iran is not actually
connected to our national security. How
many Shiite terror attacks have there
been in the United States in my
lifetime? Let me do the math. Zero. So
don't tell me that the greatest threat
we face is Iran. That's a lie. You're
telling it on behalf of a foreign power.
Maybe they feel the greatest threat they
face is Iran. It's not the greatest
threat we face. It's not an endorsement
of Iran. Okay? Doesn't make me a s for
the Shiites. It just makes me an
American who's trying to think clearly
about what our problems are. And our
problems would include tens of millions
of foreign nationals living illegally in
my country. Nobody knows their
identities. They would include a
collapsing economy that makes it very
hard for my children to have children
and live the life that they grew up with
and and their friends and all American
kids. It would include a drug crisis
that's killed millions of Americans over
the past 20 millions of Americans over
the last 20 years. Iran is not even in
the top 10 list. So you can scream at me
all you want and call me names and call
me a bigot or whatever, but I just
there's no evidence to support that. And
so if the energy of the US government is
focused on a threat that's not the
primary threat to us, it is by
definition ignoring threats that are.
Thank you. Exactly. The only threat that
is Iran is a threat to is what? Israel.
Even that um it's not America. So it's
clear guys. Alhamdulillah. And you can
see Subhan Allah. And I urge you guys to
go to rethink911.org,
watch Tuck Coulson's um documentary and
wake yourself up if you don't know about
this. I came across this was one of the
reasons I came to Islam. One of the
reasons because I can remember I was
like wow this is all a big fat lie man
and one thing I will ask Allah on the
day of judgment bro is like a movie I
want to see how they orchestrated this
evil plot against all of those innocent
people Americans Jewish people that died
Muslims that got killed Christians that
have been killed. I really want to see
subhan Allah how their evil plot was and
hellfire is sufficient for them. Till
next time.